(Destin) Alright man, so the organization is called Not Forgotten.
So, what does that mean?
- Not Forgotten. Ah, we're basically
telling the kids that they are not forgotten. Um.
That despite the fact that they've been abandoned or abused, that people are out there who care about them
and love them.
- Got it, and that's you?
- That's us.
-Got it.
-We're on their team.
- Excellent. Alright, so let's do this.
Not Forgotten. Hey it's me Destin, welcome to
Iquitos Peru. It's a city of 400,000 and we're in morning rush hour
traffic. For the last week a buddy of mine named CJ and I have been working
on a concrete crew. We're working on a
septic tank for an orphanage. It's pretty awesome. So today,
we're gonna learn about how to use levers. You'd be amazed what they can do with simple
machines down here. You're getting Smarter Every Day.
[Music]
OK I'm gonna use my lunch to teach you about levers.
For levers there's three things you need to know and that's F R E 1 2 3.
F is fulcrum. Fulcrum is the point that you pivot about.
R is resistance. In this case it's the fish that I'm gonna eat, and E is the effort.
So when I push down on the effort, then I pick up my resistance by pivoting
on my fulcrum. For a class 1 lever, the fulcrum is in the middle.
For a class 2 lever, the resistance is in the middle, the fulcrum's on one side
and the effort's on the other. And finally for class 3,
the effort's in the middle, and the fulcrum and the resistance are on the outsides.
F R E 1 2 3. Whatever letter,
corresponds with the number, that is what is in the center of the lever. Check out this video from
the work site and see if you can identify different classes of levers.
[Music]
(Destin) That's smart.
[Dialogue in Spanish]
So what's really cool about this project is we're able to use our time,
talent and knowledge to work on something much larger than ourselves. It's really fun
but if you think about it, it's not the first time that levers have been used in Peru to build something really big
out of smaller things is it. Anyway if you think this project's pretty cool and you want to donate to
the effort, use us and Not Forgotten as the fulcrum, and then lift up abandoned children,
then all you have to do is check out the link in the video description below and you can donate if you're interested
in that. If not, just remember this. F R E 1 2 3
and you can always remember what class a lever is. I'm Destin, you're getting Smarter Every Day.
Have a good one. So here on the job site there's only one rule,
and that's obey the pepe. Si pepe? [laugh]
Fidel is the boss and you do what he says. If he says do it, you do it fast,
you jump, si? That works.
I'm a mechanical engineer so I'm focusing on the details of the structure
and this is my buddy CJ. He is a systems engineer so he's focusing on
the overall project, getting things done. And we are here at a home for boys.
This is kind of what we're trying to set up with Not Forgotten.
Oh. Limit.
- Limitus.
(Destin) It's close to calculus. So you're almost doing calculus.
That's awesome. So you can see here in the boys home
they're learning all kinds of cool stuff.
So that's what we're trying to do
[laugh]
[ Captions by Andrew Jackson ]
captionsbyandrew.wordpress.com
Captioning in different languages welcome.
Please contact Destin if you can help.